es ist absolut paradox eine bestimmte
gruppe roter riesenstern bereitet
forschungsteams weltweit schlaflose
nächte
denn diese sterne sind alt und jung
zugleich oder scheinen zumindest ihre
großen massen weisen auf ein junges
alter hin
ihr stern material dagegen scheint sehr
alt zu sein welches rätsel steckt
dahinter
deutsche wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler haben diese super
spannende rätsel jetzt gelöst klicks um
science-fiction lebens täglich
spannendes seines videos abonniert den
kanal und activity glocken und dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen die mysteriösen roten
riesenstern wurden bereits vor vier
jahren entdeckt und sind seitdem ein
großes rätsel für die astronomie
weltweit dazu die physikerin saskia
henker die die sterne damals mit
aufgespürt hatte die sterne schienen
gleichzeitig alt und jung zu sein dieser
widerspruch hat mich nicht mehr
losgelassen
verschiedene messungen hatten nämlich
sehr unterschiedliche ergebnisse
hinsichtlich des alters dieser stern
ergeben
teilweise lagen die ergebnisse der
verschiedenen alters messungen
unglaubliche vier milliarden jahre
auseinander dabei ist die
altersbestimmung von stern heutzutage
eigentlich gar keine besondere sache
mehr auch wenn man ihnen ihr alter auf
den ersten blick nicht unbedingt ansieht
können fachleute die lebensgeschichte
eines sterns rekonstruieren und zwar
sehr genau dazu gibt es mittlerweile
verschiedene methoden die äußerst
verlässliche ergebnisse liefern warum
also geben die roten riesenstern dabei
so einen widerspruch auf sind sie so alt
wie sie ihr stern material andeutet oder
sind sie so jung so wie es ihre masse
nämlich die sterne enthalten eher wenig
eisen was darauf schließen lässt dass
die sterne mehr als zehn milliarden
jahre alt sein müssen
geht man nach ihrer masse dürften nicht
sternen dagegen nicht älter als maximal
6 milliarden jahre seien ein wirklich
stellares paradoxon also doch ein
forschungsteam vom max planck institut
für sonnensystemforschung mps hat dieses
rätsel jetzt gelöst bei ihrer analyse
nahmen die fachleute die mengen an
kohlenstoff sauerstoff und stickstoff
genauer unter die lupe
die aus den kernen der sterne an die
oberfläche gewirbelt wird aus dem
verhältnis konnten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
dann rückschlüsse daraus ziehen wie heiß
und massereich der stern ist zudem geben
die
verhältnisse der elemente auch hinweise
auf das alter der roten riesen mit hilfe
dieser spektral daten nämlich lassen
sich die vorgänge im stern inneren
rekonstruieren
eine wirklich spannende spurensuche also
und das ergebnis ist verblüffend die
fachleute sind sich sicher dass die
roten riesenstern ihr junges alter nur
vortäuschen demnach sind die sterne also
sehr alt sowie ist ihr stern material
schon nahegelegt hatte
dazu heißt es in der studie diese sterne
sind massereich haben aber relativ
niedrige stickstoff kohlenstoff
verhältnisse heißt also im klartext die
chemische signatur der stern entspricht
denen von leichtgewichten von außen
betrachtet dagegen handelt es sich bei
den roten riesen um schwergewichte dazu
dass autorinnen und autoren team bevor
sie zu roten riesen wurden müssen diese
sterne noch vergleichsweise leicht
gewesen sein
ihr hohes gewicht ist somit keine
ursprüngliche eigenschaft und eignet
sich nicht so altersbestimmung sie sind
in wirklichkeit alt doch ihre
entstehungsgeschichte erklärt warum die
sterne die jugendlichkeit vortäuschen
wahrscheinlich hat eine sternen
kollision zu der entstehung dieser
paradoxen sterne geführt laut der
aktuellen studie sind diese sterne
nämlich in einer fortgeschrittenen phase
ihrer entwicklung mit anderen sternen
verschmolzen
zwei alte aber eher kleine sterne wurden
so zu einem massereichen gebilde
somit wird auch ihr heutiges hohes
gewicht erklärt diese ergebnisse
verhelfen den fachleuten zu einem
besseren verständnis über die
kollisionen und verschmelzungen von
sternen doch das astronomenteam schreibt
selbst dass dieser erklärungsansatz
nicht für alle untersuchten sterne
zutrifft denn bei manchen passt die
bestimmte masse gut zu dem vorkommen der
elemente stickstoff sauerstoff und
kohlenstoff an ihrer oberfläche
das forschungsteam mutmaßt dass diese
sterne bereits in einer früheren phase
ihrer entwicklung mit anderen
verschmolzen sind
doch bewiesen ist diese erklärung noch
nicht der letzte stern im universum rote
zwerge erklärt anklicken anschauen und
kurz gesagt den kanal unbedingt
abonnieren mega cooler kanal bis dann
bleibt dran